well I don't want to miss this story
uh-huh Oh sly grin yeah so little known
fact one of your first investors was
Paul Graham of why company yeah can you
tell us about that meeting what what
convinced PG to write you a check yeah
it was it was hilarious yeah so it was
actually it started at demo day and I
was lucky to be invited so we'd gone
we'd presented last and we'd been told
the whole time that like you know the
goal was to meet lots of people to get
them to come by and like talk to you
right and so a good way to do that is to
have like good metrics and we were lucky
we had this good growth curve but
another way to get to do that is donuts
and so I had a box of donuts and I said
at the end that like hey they were over
there there's a box on a table like
goodbye and so hmm and so so the
presentations finished and we were kind
of milling around we ride our little
stand thing hoping that people would pop
by and who walks over but but PG and he
goes to Liam he's like hey I read
there's one of the metrics we showed I
think there's an engagement metric he's
like I really like that but the look of
that like do you remember what that was
I don't remember that when I'm sure I've
got it in there I think it was something
about every three seconds oh you're so
rewarding feedback maybe I did you
remember and I do yeah no I don't
actually remember it's it's I've got it
in the the pitch deck something I'm sure
you guys have it to fit yeah yeah and so
he's like I really like that metric can
you show me like that what the growth
curve and that looks like and and then
like a I can't even imagine what was
happening for Liam because he and I and
we'd like read all of Peters essays for
ages right this is like like a legendary
person turning up and just like having a
normal conversation with you
and and so poor Liam was just like come
like a holy [ __ ] you know it's like oh
my god like my my my idol is here and
I'm like wow I don't have it to hand but
I can pull it or whatever in and
peih-gee is like oh yeah you could just
open terminal and do it in there right
make it like base like starts coaching
him through their names like names like
very like he's an amazing technology
very confident right when he's like he's
like oh yeah I guess I'll just do that
inter but it's gonna take a while and
the donuts kind of kind of bit us in the
bit us in the ass repeaters I guess okay
I'll just stand here and have a doughnut
okay so you've got this like high
pressure like data extraction happening
for Liam and in the end Liam's like
looks like it's better than this I'll
just email it to you like straight after
this and so so Paul gives us his email
address and he's like that sounds good
moves away and so we go home like
breathlessly excited I don't remember
like the rest of what happened at demo
day and we craft this email to PG or DM
does he's like hey here's the metric you
want to look at the growth curve
whatever and we send it off and like
nothing like crickets and we're like I
guess he wasn't like that interested
like it was just polite right but but
being relentless with this stuff
two days later we Imam again and you
know the numbers are small so they're
growing rate we're like look it's grown
Mike's like 3 X 0 2 and and again like
no answer and we keep doing this for
like I think the best part of like a
week like every day or two or just
emailing like a another char another and
and then sort of it from Liam's email
and then I get an email from poor like a
week later with one-liner where he says
it is customary to respond the to offers
of funding and we're like what does that
mean indeed yes yeah and we're like yes
agree she won something else with that
and then we check out Liam as some kind
of super juiced up kind of Gmail inbox
whatever and it's like it's like in a
spam folder somewhere is like like two
days in PG is like okay I'm in and like
whatever I'll write you guys a check and
just come around pick it up and we're
like we're Ezek spammed PG for the best
pop a week after
and then yeah then Liam biked to to his
house to pick up the check which is kind
of cool yeah think he's having a nap in
the shed tell us about who uses
classdojo and what problem they're
trying to solve when they adopt
classdojo
yeah it's uh I think it's important
understand like what like why class
surgery even exists and then that gets
like the problem is that we're actually
helping people solve so that the reason
we started the company really is because
I kind of thought that most kids like
don't get the education that's gonna
make them be happy and successful and
it's bleak that's bleak yeah but but
what's happy the good thing about it is
that I think like the answer is ready
they're like the answer isn't like some
magic technology or a magic policy is
actually like education is really a
product that's made by people in
classrooms and in homes and so our job
as a company then becomes to help people
in classrooms and homes create a better
education experience for kids and so
like that's really like what class have
just been trying to do for a long long
time right from the start of a company
and then so that the exact set of
problems that we've tried to solve
changes quite a lot right depending on
the classroom depending on what where
kids are what kinds of things teachers
want to do but I'd say like probably the
two main problems we solve today one is
that there's this there's this weird
like gulf between school and home
so like kids go off to school for like
eight hours a day and a bunch of stuff
happens in a classroom and then they go
home and a bunch stuff happens at home
and like the the kind of the two halves
the day don't really like connect and
then right talk to each other but that's
really like a kid's life growing up it's
like usually you like one of those two
settings and it's a bit odd because I
can every other part your life you're
connected to the things you care most
about and make like Instagram or
whatever but but it's very odd for
parents that they're not more connected
to their kids for like most of the day
and for teachers who actually really
care about these kids that they don't
really get a view of what's happening at
home and so we really like that's one
big problem we try and help with is like
bridging that that gulf and make
creating more of a connect
between school and home and then the
second problem has a newer one but it's
really this this it's kind of like
teachers have struggled for a long time
to try new ideas in their classroom so
like the the pace at which new ideas get
introduced to classrooms is actually
quite slow and and it takes quite a long
time for a teacher to try a new practice
they might have heard of like I know
personalized learning or like something
like a growth mindset like a new idea
and it's quite tough and so we're trying
to like help teachers try more ideas in
their classrooms and make it easier and
faster for teachers to bring new ideas
into their classrooms how does your
product make that easier for them oh
yeah so the the first people so for the
first part and we basically just helped
teachers share more of what's happening
at school every day so teachers can
share pictures and videos through the
school day home so this this new bit was
from like a couple of years ago where
and in a kind of it wasn't really like a
plan it kind of emerged from something
one of the teams was doing so we spend a
lot of time in classrooms and always
have and we kept hearing this thing
about social and emotional learning like
there are lots and lots of teachers who
really want to teach their kids things
beyond like reading and writing and math
but like software skills and and it was
really tough for them because it's a
quite a fuzzy area they're like well
what do we do next Mike I want to teach
my kid my kids about curiosity or or
creativity or empathy these are like
important things for people to learn but
we don't really know how to teach them
and so a few years ago we went down the
road to Stanford and there's a professor
there account-link and she's got this
you know right now I don't have everyone
this thing knows but you know and she's
got this idea called the growth mindset
it's a really famous TED talk and just
got book about it and it's basically
idea that like you're you know you're
not fixed in your abilities and that
through practice and persistence you can
get better at stuff but it's amazing how
many kids grow up without that idea
really in mind right they're kind of
told you're a math person know you're
not a creative person and these are
really like quite limiting mindsets and
so we wanted to see if we could help
teachers like undo
that like just start with that one idea
see if we could help more teachers share
this idea for growth mindset because
they'd already talked about wanting it
and like we heard it from them and so he
went to Carol Dweck and her team and we
were like look if we could get this idea
to lots and lots of schools what would
we do and Noam and together came with
this idea of like making short stories
like animated shorts three to five
minute
you know like thought starters or
conversation starters for classrooms and
so we produced there's the most like
hack job I think we've ever done that
was like eight weeks from like the first
conversation to getting this series done
we did it all in-house it was like three
people in like a tiny room and but we
made this series of like five animated
shorts about growth mindset and they
they they weren't really like you've got
the Khan Academy car lectures they
weren't really lecture there just like
stories and at the end of the story
there's a question so it didn't really
give you the answer is just that the
story like teeing up some interesting
thoughts for you to discuss and so we
made this series and we put it out we
distributed it on classdojo so what
every teacher about a class schedule
account it popped up in the app one day
for them it's like hey you can teach
your kids about growth mindset and it
was crazy because we'd never done
anything like it before and we didn't
know how it'd be used but we ended up
with something like it's it's something
that I think those videos have reached
about fifteen million kids now in
classrooms which is like nuts yeah and
so that was the first time we ever did
anything about this like bringing new
ideas to your classroom and then we did
a follow up with Harvard on empathy with
with Yale or mindfulness and there's
more kind so it's literally the teacher
says we want to be able to do this and
you say we'll create it for you Oh we'll
find experts don't worth much yeah but
there are experts on it and if we can
it's not just facilitating things that
happen in the classroom it's actually
providing it's actually helping people
move class misfortune if you really if
you really believe the thing that I said
that most kids don't get the education
that they should get for now in the
future and and do you believe that
teachers want to do the right things for
kids then I think it's important to help
teachers not just do what's right even
done more efficiently but actually help
them do new stuff yeah and how are you
measuring the success of teaching your
growth mindset yes
really good questions so like the
there's kind of two there's like an
input and an output measure right yeah
and the input measure for us is read
just like do people use this okay in so
used meaning like user app you watch the
video do people watch the video do they
do the activities in the classroom do
they share home with parents yeah
and so that's quite good like like
effort to measure I think the the real
truth with the growth mindset stuff is
that like the output measures I think
are like from what we can tell from
research they like take a bit longer
thank you they're mostly like psychology
research and it takes a bit longer to
really see if people's mindsets have
changed so I think like there's this
question that comes up a lot of like
should you do stuff that people use
should you do stuff that's like like
high efficacy I think it's actually like
a false trade-off but I think you have
to be clear about what today we know how
to measure and we don't know how to
measure hmm and the thing that like we
can measure is like are people
voluntarily adopting and using this like
is their demand for this and the thing
that's gonna take a little time to
figure out is like hey is the whole
world now having more of a growth
mindset but what we do know is that like
you know for 50 million kids they've
been exposed the idea for growth mindset
and they're using the words in the
classroom and they're using things like
you know it's not that I can't do this I
can't do this yet and like that that's
kind of a cool like starting point I
think I don't think well I think we're
far from done with it yeah yeah great so
from from the beginning of the company
you've you've been very effective at
talking to your users in such a way that
you really understand their problems I
think here and and you're describing now
you know as the company grows you're
you're gathering this from your users
and and giving them the things they
really want for their classrooms can you
talk a little bit about how the in the
in that early stage before you knew what
your product or even maybe your audience
was how you figured out how you
developed like what are strategies for
developing that deep understanding of
your audience what are some specific
things you did early on and that you
continue to do to keep that connection
so you can be building the right things
solving the right problems yeah that's
so that's that's a good one it's a
really important like team in the
company we talk a lot about empathy
a lot I think like so before we even
came up with like the idea for the first
product we ever built actually like I
think something people might not know is
it like lasted it didn't actually start
I mean you remember it can I mean
actually starts like a company it came
really from like I had worked in
education for most of my life like in
classrooms around classrooms Liam had
been my co-founder had been doing a PhD
in computer science focused on
technology in classrooms and so it
recant more like a passion for
educationally stuff and when we turned
up in California to do imagined k12 like
we basically didn't know anyone in
America at all like we'd never lived in
America we never worked here like we'd
met like sky called Jeff Ralston on my
video called once right like who like
Tim an hour on there as well um and and
so it kind of enforced like a naivety
either way like it kind of removed any
sense of like hey we know what we're
doing and we'll just we've got the idea
and we'll go and do an idea so it kind
of enforced that like get out and like
try and understand what people who are
actually doing this need and so the
first like for things like six weeks
yeah we heard for six or seven weeks
before we launched the first version of
classdojo seven weeks and in those seven
weeks I is Mercy Me but Liam was
involved too I did basically anything to
get in front of teachers to get to
classrooms and talk to people and so
that like on the on the easier side it
was some schools published like teachers
email addresses just on the website and
so I'd like just email people and it's
kind of a weird email right so it wasn't
like a pitch for anything it was more
hey like worthy like I told my bit about
us and I'm like we'd love to help in any
way that we can with whatever you're
doing in your classrooms and Michael
said what's the worst problem that you
face every day like just please let us
know is like a one like asking for like
a one-line respond just let us know what
the worst problem you face every day and
so we did that I think I'm out a few
thousand people and it was like scraping
email addresses it was like I've had a
friend at Teach for America I got the
emails on the email list there we
I had friends who are teachers in the UK
and Australia we kind of emailed just as
many peels we could but the other thing
which was like more probably like if
you'd step up the difficulty of it was
um we'd go to local schools and so like
we were in Palo Alto there's a gun high
school nearby mm-hmm and I found it a
few teachers there who were willing to
talk to me and I went towards summer
school there in fact for like a couple
of days just so they there they promised
to like like if you can cook you've
taught if you could teach like summer
school for an afternoon sure we'll chat
with you after scum like coal I'll do
that we went like teacher meetups there
are these things called the ED camp
there's actually one ed camp which was
really like life-changing for us which
I'll tell you about a minute but like we
went to these teacher meetups or just
like as much as you can to soak in the
context of your users like that's what
we did that's what I did in the early
days for a lot of it made a particularly
horrific one once where we had to go to
Los Altos School District and we were
like pretty stingy Brits and so we
didn't have like didn't want to get a
cat at goober wasn't around then we'd
never get a cab so we like biked from
miles in like the steaming South Bay Sun
to get there and turn up just dripping
with sweat there's audiences reread but
you kind of like you couldn't just do
whatever it takes right like when you're
two guys in a room and you need to get
to to understanding like how you can
actually help people you do whatever it
takes oh I suppose I think three or four
hundred people on skype calls face to
face in those seven weeks and emailed a
few thousand more and then as the
company's kind of grown that's just
become like an institution in the
company like its I think there were only
30 people but we may be unusual in that
we have like research as a function in
the company like there are researchers
in the company who spend all of their
time talking to teachers we have like
lots of ways of bringing teacher context
in and kids and parents know as well but
bringing that into the office I could
certainly the story is up on monitors
like we have community groups or we
solicit feedback all the time so I think
like that
that's a second's important part of how
we build class that jacket is that a
vestige of you working in consulting or
do you think it's just like fits the
company because I saw that you worked at
McKinsey and this is a very common
question like hey I'm working in
consulting thinking about doing a
start-up what do I do
yeah and it's like this consultant vers
entrepreneur like get your hands dirty
mindset right yeah mine is a bit weird
because like consulting was kind of the
anomaly for me okay so I was in my teens
encounter you know this like in my teens
the school I went to actually insisted
that you teach as well as learn so I
ended up teaching for like 20 hours a
week for six years from aged clearway
here's to our peers yeah okay well and
many of us thought it was crazy it was
but it's also one of the most effective
things you can do it's like you know the
high cost that's right
low cost high quality interventions is
peer tutoring and so like we had this in
our school we had like I would teach
regularly teach classes of 20 to 30 kids
for like around 20 hours of with your
subject that's all of them right like
you know everything yeah yeah I mean
you'd go across like physics chemistry
economics maths is it really like one
like really fascinating kind of school
but um but see so I taught for like a
long time when I got to college and I
was an economist like I'm a math person
I thought I would carry on other PhD in
that and I ended up going to teach
straight after college instead and so
like all the conventional consulting
banking didn't really appeal that mm-hm
that much but then McKinsey you're very
good at the the CRM system kind of
follow up then they're like they track
where you go and I was like oh I'm going
to teach and they're like Howard we've
got this education team here you should
come and join the you know like do some
education work really and there are a
lot kind of advising governments on how
to set up education systems and so so I
went there and I spent a bunch of my
time there in education and and
ultimately the reason you just said is
the reason I left that like I think
there's only so long like if you're used
to like getting your hands dirty there's
only so long you can like advise people
and not actually do the work yeah and so
I think it was that was more like the
way that I'd always been consulting was
like the kind of the left heard a bit
but yeah okay that's good but it wasn't
for me forever so you talk to these
hundreds of teachers and released this
first product
tell us about the early days of growth
what you think drove that and and how
that's shifted over time what
have there been transition points where
class toda went from kind of this growth
engine to this other one have you
anticipated or managed those transitions
and what do you do now ya know it's a
but tell us about that early growth so
we had our first like seven weeks or six
seven weeks or so of talking a teacher
is like building like little prototypes
and things and then week eight I
remember this because it was a Sunday
morning and we'd put the first version
of classes like live for anyone to sign
up for and it was it was quite early on
Sunday it was something like it was like
six or seven in the morning and there
was this IDI camp in in Auckland so an
ed camp is Rea just like a group of
teachers coming together at the weekend
to talk to each other about like new
things they're trying out so it's kind
of like teacher professional development
camp but they're doing it at Skyline
High School in Oakland and and we were
in Palo Alto all the time and I woke up
at 6 7 I was like oh man like I make the
sauce like we'd been sprinting or we
together this product out and I was I
probably just blow this off at like if
you'd nice to have a lion and I thought
I'd I don't know what it was but I
posted I think it's on Facebook and I
posted like I also don't have a way to
get there as I can't bike that far like
the cab's gonna be really expensive in
their back and so I post on I think it
was Facebook and I said does anyone
going towards Oakland today like on the
off chance everyone's going I'd love a
ride and then turns out another person
from our imagined k12 class Chris reader
in fact was and he was like I'll pick
you up and go and I was oh so it's a
good lesson to you know trying to be the
hardest working person in the room right
but I come but Chris tripped me out went
to the head camp and base just starting
there was like something at 80 or 90
teachers there and we're just chatting
they're like oh like you're not a
teacher what are you up to and I told me
about this thing that we've been working
on about class dojo and and they're like
oh that sounds really fascinating and
they're like two or three of them we're
like I might I might like check
like tell some friends about it as well
and so we couldn't have these two things
though the people we'd already spoken
with who you can imagine like the most
magical experience you could get is
someone turns up and says hey we just
want to solve a problem for you and then
goes and build something that tries to
solve the problem like that's like a
good experience for you it's a very
white-glove kind of service and so a
bunch of people got that those does that
was the the 400 teachers or so that I'd
spoken with and then this new set we're
like oh that might work for me as well
and and then they started using it and
they like tweeted out too like a twitter
is actually big for us in the early days
they start telling like their their
teacher followers and friends about it's
a few of them turn out to be quite like
influential like thought leader type
teachers and and so by the end of that
first week we had fat something like 80
teachers using it every day
and we're like this is amazing over 280
was like just an unimaginable number for
this in the summertime why isn't this
was like that right at the end of the
summer okay is like I think we'd go to
the last week of July or first week of
August a so schools are not really in
session for that well you've got this is
this one the secrets was like these
teachers are already preparing for like
what's coming at the end of you but it's
already trying things out there already
like setting up classes and all that
kind of stuff
so this was like kind of crazy we're
like wow there's people like virtually
picking this thing up and then what
happened was from then through demo day
which I think was like the end of August
or September early September yes is
exactly a month like four or five weeks
or so and it had gone from like 80
teachers like yes an act like a few
thousand people using it and we're like
like this is just blown our minds right
we're like this is kind of crazy that um
then it's just Brennan and all of that
was purely through the product it was
just like we had we didn't have a say
through the product it wasn't like some
clever viral flow or whatever it was
like one teacher using it or saying this
will solve plumbing for me and then
spreading it to other teachers and so
we'd find one teacher in school would
pick it out and then it would like
travel through the whole school and and
that happened a lot in the in the early
days so that was kind of early stuff it
was kind of we weren't we weren't doing
a huge amount on
trying to drive growth who is more just
like building a good product but a
little bit later probably the biggest
turning point and it's this thing that
continues to this day was we went to
observe a teacher's classroom and Bessie
Carmichael elementary here in the city
and her name is Jenna Klein and so so we
went to sit in a classroom and pretty
awesome teacher shoe science teacher I
think she's a great classroom and
whatever and she's using dojo and um
like if we thought nothing more of it we
had a bunch of research nerds went back
to the product team is rubber two months
later I get email from from Jenna and
she was like hey I'm thinking of
transitioning out of the classroom and
I'd love to come and do an internship
with you guys like would you be up for
that and you know we were like six
people everything there like I don't
know we're do with an intern and we're
like yeah sure like you know we've
probably got no like support or
something that needs doing like you can
come and help out and so so she joined
for the summer and she's doing a bunch
of like support stuff and at the end of
the summer we're like well I guess she's
going back to teaching now and she she
came to me and said Sam I think we're
really missing a trick with with
community and I was like what do you
mean community I was like we're building
product it's right there and them and
she was like no no no like I found this
thing we're like you know you'll get one
teacher in school who loves this and
then spreads it to other teachers and
it's a real pattern and here's how like
the growth rate of like she done
basically the whole analysis of like how
schools were they with an influencer
teacher whose friend the word to grow
faster than other schools and and she's
got these like like she set up like a
Facebook group for a bunch of these
power you she she don't do this like
secret work basically in the summer on
community stuff and I was like um yeah I
guess we could like we can extend the
internship for a few months and just
yeah I guess and but but this was like
one of the big secrets and the company
was like teachers are like amongst the
most underserved I think people in the
world like if you think the average
teacher they get into this job which is
like you know pretty underpaid well
to most other jobs you could do it's
like often underappreciated it's really
tough and you're like on your feet with
like 30 kids all day like it's a really
tough job and so if you can if you if
you turn up and you're like hey we're
gonna be the people who like really
listen to you and help you change your
classroom to be the one that you dreamed
of run the know rather than like thing
like you've got your hands tied the
entire time it turns out they tell
people about that and and Jenna built
this crazy like like sure that not crazy
I shouldn't say that but it's like a
community of teachers who are just so
enthusiastic about changing their
classrooms and helping other teachers
change their classrooms making these
connections among your yeah it's gonna
say yeah you can you explain how that
dynamic actually works right so you say
you're looking for a teacher who will be
an advocate in any particular school
Yeah right so how are you finding them
and then what happens from them yeah so
usually they'll find classdojo and then
support them to like spread the word bit
more so Jenna made this community called
the mentor community and the mentors are
basically the first teacher in every
school that we're in okay who finds
classdojo so we still don't do that much
to spread in your schools like people it
jumps through like social networks it's
primarily organic it's full Harmonia
County we still don't pay for user
acquisition so um so it's all like
word-of-mouth but but once it gets to a
school then we really support that
mentor to spread the word and to bring
all the teachers long if they think it's
good like we don't want we don't want
like a top-down implementation we don't
want the principal to grab it and push
it on there and one we want it to spread
like in a grassroots way and so Jenna
built this whole like community which is
like supportive of each other and
supportive like spreading the word and
and that's like a really again it's a
power it's a committee with a purpose
which you classes a movement and that's
like a really powerful thing and so I
think the turning point versus Jenna and
like if strategy one was just like good
product obsessively listening to people
and and serving them strategy two then
was building a supportive community that
is excited about like a different future
for education and I think that's that's
like a secret the community stuff I
don't think many companies really
understand well mmm-hmm did Jenna stay
with you yeah she still with us today
yeah she's she's awesome good job Jenna
yeah
that's awesome so Janice with you and
your more than six people put it ball
team still it's still still pretty small
team and and classdojo so can you give
us a sense of the reach your reach now
in terms of the product yeah yeah I'm we
usually talk about the percentage of
schools that were in so in the US were
in like 90 percent of K through 8
schools in the country now there's about
a hundred thousand schools or so okay
you're in about a hundred thousand oaks
here and so there may be one teacher
maybe one there's more and more it's
like whole schools but it's at least one
being active okay and then this is
actually the first year that we're
bigger internationally than in the US so
more schools outside the US now using a
pen in the u.s. so more than 200
thousand schools using it then
okay got it and about half of those in
the US so it's so you're you're used by
all of these schools and you guys have
raised over thirty million dollars in
funding but you're still a team of just
thirty and well it's that unusual given
that where you are and was it a
conscious decision to kind of keep the
team at this size and run lean can you
tell us about that thinking and and kind
of how you make that work if if that's
unusual yeah I mean judging by the way
you're asking it sounds pretty unusual
absolutely yeah I think it's like the
average company would be much bigger I
think that count yeah yeah yeah yeah no
it's um so many something we've thought
a lot about it's definitely intentional
there's a there's a few things for me
one is that like I think it's always
surprising how much small teams can get
done and I think there's actually like
large diminishing returns like very very
large teams and so for dojo like we've
kind of been informed by there's a great
book called team of teams on this I keep
plugging this book everywhere but I'm
like okay but yeah it's it's basically
like how you create I'm really
interesting this as as
area of personal interest is how you
create high-performing teams and this
book talks a lot about to two concepts
like empowered execution and shared
context and so I think the conventional
way of or a conventional way of building
teams is that you hire like like the VP
who then like issues the instructions to
the troops and the troops go and execute
and I think in in like fast-moving or on
certain environments it's far more
interesting to have like a team of
leaders who are capable of making
decisions quickly and moving quickly so
I think what we've done instead of
building very large teams is build like
like it the 30 people are structured and
like even smaller teams right like we
have prior development teams which are
anywhere between like three to ten
people a mix of engineers pm's designers
etc and so we we try and have each of
the teams having like a clear mission
that they all believe in and and are
empowered to execute on it so they've
got all the information they need so
internally in the company everything is
public like we have board decks or
public financials of public you have all
the information to make like a globally
optimal decision about what you should
do next
rather than my just getting a sliver of
information and having to to march
forward on that and so I think that's
actually how you get them like how you
get the most from people is when people
are like really bought in on a mission
they believe in and they feel like the
owners of that mission and so I think
we've obsessed a lot over building that
kind of culture I don't think we always
get it right but we've seen great
returns to to really obsessing of like
the right kind of culture and so we
could certainly do with many more people
on the team like I'm not saying that
this is like you know this is where I'll
stay now in fact we'd like our first
recruiter just joined last week so I've
done all the recruiting so far but um
but um I do think the small team thing
is like really undervalued I think even
get small high-performing teams working
you can scale those a lot and there's
actually some of the Amazon talked about
a lot but like the two pizza teams and
things is if you can get small
autonomous teams what is the - pizza -
oh like the whole team could be federal
it so life yeah okay I can eat two
pizzas so yeah that's why I do all the
podcasts on my own so what would you
advise people who
want to adopt that same strategy but
they're also used to doing all the stuff
they're like I want to do all the
recruiting because so far I've recruited
30 great people yeah and how do you like
how do you train yourself to let go yeah
I think so specifically for me as CEO I
think it's the there's this great thing
in dahlias book principles of like what
your job becomes and he's got this
diagram just based like goals machine
results okay and the machine is just
people in culture and like from
periodically you kind of want to step
back and think about like the design of
the machine and like what your role is
in the machine and then bend it Evans
actually is a good post on this it's
about Amazon he calls it the machine
that builds the machine mmm and um
and I love that but I think this is like
a it's an important thing to be able to
get some distance and reflect on like
what the right what the appropriate role
for you and the company is I think
actually Sam almond said this that you
gets about 25 people and your job shifts
from building the product to building
the culture and it kind of stays there
and that's that's so true right like my
like the reason I've just replaced
myself with a actual recruiter yeah is
that that's not the right job for me
anymore there are other parts of the
culture that I need to focus on and
build so I think it's to answer your
question I think it's having a
retrospective loop on what your role as
CEO is in but designing the whole
machine and then your part in that
machine
mm-hmm okay what other books have been
helpful for you in developing a
leadership in you have product strategy
oh there's a lot there's um we have we
have pretty obsessive reading culture
and every month and like like what most
people like do I think an hour or so of
reading a day at least but yeah it's
it's quite good but um there's been a
few so total bad team of teams there's
extreme ownership is another good one
there's kinda like that convention like
the zero to one and if this startup
people this sort of he kind of yes yeah
I'm trying to pull up my Kindle and
think of what some of the unusual ones
are but I really love principles when
you write it a while ago yeah it's only
a little bit of extreme but I think it's
it's quite good mm-hmm
there's one called the evolution of
everything which like that the main
message from it was I think it's very
easy to believe the world is like
designed in some way and embracing like
emergence in the company for like for
instance the the growth mindset videos I
spoke about like that was an emergent
idea that wasn't
CEO said we have to do growth mindset
videos that was like one of our product
development teams like came up with this
insight and now that's like a major part
of what we do at dojo and so that the
embracing the idea of emergence is are
really really important and do you draw
inspiration from books that aren't about
business yeah I mean there's a there's a
lot there's one I'm really motor called
the diamond age which seems there seems
quite good okay yeah I'm quite already
on it but um I'm the ones that are
coming to mind for me now with all the
ones I've read recently yeah
Karen okay what was what was Sam like in
the early what do you remember about him
in the early days of American k12 sure
yeah cuz we met when you you moved to
America to build this startup but you
didn't know what this startup was yet
it's just valuable because so many
people like listening to podcasts or
watch videos even like the authors
you're talking about right oh this is
Jacko's book he's so hard
what's the workout plan yeah just some
guy like they're just he was an eighteen
year old at some point and the same is
true for all of us right so I think that
perspective is would be interesting if
you remember it early there's a Sam I
remember I mean you're very easy to talk
Sam is very easy to talk to and so that
kind of stands out and I think was
probably part of what made that early
learning from customers so well but yeah
I remember you know those early months
it seemed like a very stressful time
because you didn't know exactly what
demo day was coming
product didn't exist yet the idea was
taking form but Sam and Liam will just
kind of show up and be like yeah we're
working we're getting all this you know
we're talking all these
people and we're kind of wondering
what's gonna come in this what's gonna
come with this bed and mr. king plasto
and I have this vivid memory of Sam
you're talking about your your frugal
British nature Sam wear glasses the
glasses still holding them to his face
because that was missing and is there a
word for that like the love of like
patching things together in the UK we
can see it with houses too
yeah you know there's like the idea of
like the crazy like British inventor
yeah there's I think like the one person
to shadow ever I think that's actually
Liam That's not me but like that's I
think that's there should be a word for
it yeah yeah it was just dangling still
seem to serve their purpose yeah that
you don't need to really it's really
proud and what has changed since you
guys to just start like I'm sure you had
it some degree of vision right in the
beginning and what you thought the
product would be what what changed what
were some big realizations oh man yeah
that's that's a that's a big question -
what's been amazing is like the the core
thesis that I said the start that like I
I actually think education is made by
people not by technology and the role
technology is in service of people
supporting them that thesis hasn't
changed like from from those early
conversations it became pretty clear
that like the best way we could have
impact was by serving teachers helping
them like connect with the kids and
parents and then helping them improve
their classrooms and that would be a way
to both have impact and to scale hmm but
like the product I think the thing
that's changed the most is like the
actual products that we've built so
cluttered has never been like a one
product company I think like the first
prom we ever worked on was helping
teachers build a better classroom
culture and that was just or just a
product for teachers to use inside the
classroom later on it became far more
important for us to share beyond the
classroom to include the whole community
families also other teachers and the
principal in the school and so it became
much more of a network
product than just like a single-player
kind of thing and then the thing that
changed after that was that network
could then be used to share more and
more ideas right and so that was
probably the the latest evolution says
it's kind like that the product I think
has changed a lot yeah I think the
thesis with a company stayed largely the
same okay and was there were there
learnings that may be counterintuitive
that are maybe I guess it could be for
EdTech specifically or just a startup in
general I'm always curious to see what
people pick up along the way that they
didn't expect at all in the beginning
that you thought you would advise other
founders to keep it actually wrote some
of these down I mean just know what
holds up yeah I thought about this once
I saw it yeah I think like what one the
ones me is this thing of this we talked
about a bit but like the small teams
thing because the whole way we've always
been pushed by investors to like just
like you've got to like hire more people
and grow faster and whatever and even me
think about this a bit from from the
realities of the education world like
you work in school years so there's no
point you being alive for like three out
of the 12 months of the school year you
better be around in 12 month like chunks
and so I know that's counterintuitive
but it's not obvious from the outside
you'd be like well we should just hire
people in like January and then you know
it's a cool but if that means you run
out of money in June then you don't get
another school year yeah so that was
good and I think like it's been
surprising it's always surprised to me
how much small teams can do so that was
a big one for me um another one for me
was like mmm the UM the the emergence
thing I think there's a narrative in
Silicon Valley that like a you know some
some kind of far forward-looking
visionary will I come down from the
mountain with the plan and then give it
to the troops and like the troops will
just go and execute it and it may be
true right like there may be people who
are just that brilliant like that that's
I think that is the case in a few
instances but for us I think we've gone
a great we've got a lot of mileage out
of just embracing the idea of like your
job isn't to like minimize the chaos
mm-hmm but it's like him
our people to think big and to be bold
about the things that they might do and
the only way you can really do that is
one by making the company a
psychologically safe place and the team
is a psychologically safe place like if
you're always being judged on like
success and failure at every moment it's
really tough for people to think big how
do you do that I mean I cuz if that's an
issue everywhere yeah
so one actually interesting thing we did
recently it wasn't so much for products
but it was across the whole organization
was we started a running log of all
issues in the company okay so this is
really weird
right and it's internally public for
everyone to see and anyone can add to it
you can add anonymously you can add like
with your name on it and so it'll be
everything from like hey like the
priorities aren't clear to hey like
we're really like creating too much
trash - what happened with that you know
that X project that we never heard about
yeah and so the idea is that like you I
think we really value building a culture
we can be like real with each other hmm
and it's never in like a hard or
arrogant it's actually like the most
empathic way that like we all we all
think this mission is like really really
important it's very important that like
every kin the world gets a better
education in a reasonable period of time
and so we're all here to do that and so
any issue that's standing in the way of
doing that like it's far better to like
drag it out into the light where it
resolved then to like have it fester
quietly and so I think that like
building the kind of company that like
quickly surfaces and resolves issues
whereas letting them fester is really
important so Mike like for that one
practice it's it's recent but you know
we review that log every week the
guarantee is that they'll always be
action taken on it like wheel prioritize
and we'll take action but you can redo
an asana and you can like follow along
so if you submit an issue you know it's
gonna get worked on the idea is not a
new one it actually came from there's a
plant called the new me plant which was
the partnership between Toyota and GM
and went from one the worst car
production factories in Fremont to one
the best in the world and it did it by
like really empowering the people doing
the work and they would guarantee that
any suggestion you put in the suggestion
box would be acted on straight away and
if and if it couldn't be at one for
summaries
they would publicly announce it within a
week why it can be acted on and so it's
like you imagine what you imagine a
factory looks like it's not it's not
that it's like you just do your little
slice of the assembly line and move on
any of it but I think I was really
counting to do that like that the
standard narratives about what what
great companies and great leaders do
which is you know set the vision tell
people what to do is like we're so far
off for us and there's strong parallels
with classrooms I don't think I think
great teachers don't tell the kids what
to do yeah you know and so it's a nice
like golden thread from inside the
company to out of it that's a great
insight I uh I used to work at the onion
and when everyone it's something that's
not necessarily obvious but the onion
doesn't have by lines in that inanimate
e is amazing for creativity Wow yeah
because it's so easier I don't know this
like might be a little racy or this is
like super weird like I don't know if I
want my name behind this headline right
it doesn't matter it's all by the onion
or if I made up people right it's like
yeah yeah that's soon it was so handy
and so yeah
to your point like I think if people
could submit you know issues anonymously
but also see it tracked yeah super
helpful especially I mean place like YC
same thing yeah like we could do a
better job yeah so your product serves a
it's a in a sense it in a sensitive
space you have sensitive audience right
you're used in schools by teachers
teaching young children and everyone's
very interested in knowing what what
young children are touching and and what
kind of lessons they're receiving and a
few years ago you had you went through
some kind of court of public opinion
trials so I want you to share about that
because I think you know every company
has to worry about how they're perceived
and how and that court of public opinion
but it's really amplified when you're
dealing with an audience that includes
when you're serving customers that
include young children yeah so I want to
see if you could share you know a little
bit about that story and what you learn
from that the kind of as a company in
terms of how you manage that side of
what you yeah
totally happy to share so you think like
this is actually I think in magical k12
had an amazing role of plan this no no
no not a bad way like so like like five
or six years ago I think we there is a
new cohort of like EdTech companies that
just like you launch into the world and
it was a really like uncertain world for
like all of us I mean you know you guys
were also building imagine k12 and like
and there's lots of learnings there
there are lots of learnings for us so we
did like the conventional thing which
was like build a product that people
love get out lots people focus on that
focus and I think that and all of us do
it because that was that was what we
were as the the conventional wisdom of
the valley at the time and I think it
was like a few years in I forget exactly
what year it was but there was really
like this sudden like oh my god like
there's all this technology in
classrooms now like where is it going is
it good is it bad what it you know et
cetera et cetera like lots and lots of
debate discussion about it and it really
like dragged a few things out to light
for me right because like the the naive
way to build products is like we'll just
build a great product and everything
else will take care of itself
and and you gross often hear that would
like founders who don't want to do sales
or for instance right but but this one
wasn't sales of all it was actually like
clear communication and so as a company
which like you know we're a lot of
introverts in the company and I used to
be very extroverted but more commonly
over time like like you kind of forget
that like that's actually like really
really important like it's important to
do it you saying so what you do and to
be clear in your communication and so
you'd had like a few years ago you had
you know a bunch of young startups who
had suddenly got to scale or some scale
interesting enough scale there it was it
was relevant who had like boilerplate
like terms and conditions or privacy
policies or hadn't updated the website
and were guilty of all of these I hadn't
update the website to like to actually
describe what you do or I had cater to
one audience like teachers but not to
like districts and so like I think the
thing that and we actually know the the
finger was they could start to solve in
the areas what was the what was the
criticism that you guys we're dealing
the prison
like yeah there are lots of criticisms
for I think not not just for us the
whole industry but Freight for us it was
like well like what happens with like
kids information right like because the
only parallel people have and there's
actually two points where one is
communication the other is like like
what's your business model right and so
the first one in communication is
important for everyone the second one if
you if you go back a few years now the
main example people had was like a
business on the internet was like
Facebook or Google like these like the
companies that often get held up right
and they're like oh like those companies
like literally take users information
you give it to advertisers and so when
companies like are working in classrooms
I don't think that's acceptable at all
like that's not like that would be a
really bad way to build and fund an
education technology company and so the
answer the insistence in the first it's
important to be clear and crisp in your
communication and I think many of us
weren't there like we you know I know a
few of us at least roaaar rewrote all of
our policies in like sixth grade
language or sixth grade level English
just so that anyone can understand right
because they have Charlie terms of
therapy yeah because legal legal jargon
is legal jargon and it's sykes confusing
and weird for everyone right but if you
write it like what does this mean that
like that that goes a long way also
being clear like hey this isn't an
advertising like company your data's not
going anywhere it's yours you can delete
it you can change it like if you don't
delete it will delete it after like X
years of inactivity or something right
so because we don't need it like it's
yours like it doesn't we don't need it
to sell to ads sell ads against and so
then the second thing was like making
sure your incentives are aligned with
your users and so for us like actually
the best business model in the world is
like also the oldest one world which is
like hey it will make some stuff for you
and if you really like it you can buy
some of it you know like asides right
for like that's all we're saying what
like a will make a bunch of stuff for
teachers and for and for parents and
we're particularly interested for
parents were like well most parents
don't really have very good choices like
most parents the world you have the
choice of if you want do something good
for your kids education if you're in the
top 10% of the population you can send
them to private
school for pay $30,000 a year but if
you're not like what do you do
and we're like well if we could give you
a better choice to make there which also
affordable etc we give you we quote the
education bundle for your kids like
would that be interesting and parents
like yeah that would be really
interesting and so I think just being
clear about these things it's something
that we weren't guilty of because we're
so had we'll guilty off because we're so
heads down like just building products
because you know make something people
want right sure and you know your
intentions but hey and and what I think
is one of those things of like leveling
up as a company where you realize like
the scope of your responsibilities
extends beyond like your own user base
and beyond like your team and beyond
it's people in classrooms who we are
obsessed with and love extends to people
who have never touched your product or
used it and they need to know too and
that was like a whole different thing we
hired a head of comms that yeah and
she's still with us and she's amazing
but that really like built a new
function at the company right that we
didn't have as you expand
internationally as you said you're now
used in more schools internationally
than in the US as that is that kind of
changing the communication needs
I mean you there are different kind of
privacy regimes and yeah you and so
forth it's yeah what do you what do you
think yeah I mean the short answer is
yes why do you do the right thing for
every jurisdiction you operate in
anything kind of interesting or you're
counterintuitive coming out of that or
it's pretty straightforward you just
kind of a fine fine I mean it's pretty
straightforward the rules are all
different but they're all in the same
spirit right like but in terms of
communicating with hearing communities
so that you know or maybe I don't know
maybe penetration in those different
countries that isn't at the level where
you're getting that scrutiny kind of in
the press and so on
well maybe it's I don't know yeah no I
mean like I said I'm a majority
international now so I mean the growth
is good but um I think like the EU is
like to kind of famous for you know
being very buttoned up on privacy so
there's well you know while ago there
was like I've got it schooled mapped it
was like the safe harbor thing and then
there was the privacy shield and so so
you just kind of have we have like
people in the company who like full-time
is their the top of that stuff um which
you don't have to think about when
you're I can you know with 80 teachers
so
I think it says like as the company
grows you have like more of these
considerations to take into account when
you're building products I got products
or go to then we have like counsel who
like looks to make sure they're
compliant with the different but it's
managing the public conversation about
you I have anything an interesting come
up there that no not non-obvious thing
that comes to mind me I'm racking my
brains think of one but that's good yeah
no no no this one I mean like I think in
general just like being clearer in
communication in all of our products
like helps everyone right it's not like
so scoped to jurisdiction if I give
every parent is that oh cool like I get
to you know share in my kids school day
now wonderful in the classrooms getting
better awesome you know it but we never
say those things before it's um you
mentioned charging parents earlier for
certain things
what is monetization look like for you
guys in the future yeah I think we've
always had this is one of the things
that hasn't changed in the start
actually yeah we've had the same view on
it that so a few principles like we we
really do want to reach like every
classroom in the world like it'll be
really good if like it's one that one
that floors with the current education
system is that I've already talked about
wonders is that like there's often
stagnation you can't get new ideas and
we meant it quickly it's all like what
would you call them like type one
decisions whether they're like big heavy
weight kind of like do we do this or not
and if you can make it like a type two
decision make it really easy to try and
reverse like wonderful I mean that
that's more innovation happen but a
second flaw in it is is the inequality
you know people will talk about how
education the u.s. is broken like it's
not actually for a few people it's
really good for a few people and for
most people like the difference being
the luckiest and the average is like
large and and so for me like that if
you're working in education there is
almost like an imperative to work on the
the equity part of it and so we don't
want to do anything that's that
prohibits us or like gets in the way of
that equity argument so we do want to
get to every classroom the world on the
on the other side I think like the
business models education have mostly
been about selling to schools and
districts and this is like slow it takes
a while that you know it would get in
the way of that that got but there's a
really interesting observation we had
I think I've already alluded to that
like parents like everywhere in the
world for the most part really care
about their kids yep that's something
we've done in a long time right for like
it's like a it's an evolutionary thing
on this one just a job it's just like
we're wired to you have to keep it alive
yeah it's a tiny person that depends on
you and so we're like well these are
also people who are like really
underserved in my view I'm like like I
said you you have fairly limited choices
you hope the school near you is really
good and that the specific teacher whose
classroom you go to is like that's
really good teacher and maybe if you can
afford it you like move houses or move
jobs whatever to get to a better school
but like you know for most of us
population that's pretty unreasonable
maybe you can go to private school if
you can pay the fees but like again
pretty unreasonable pretty out of reach
and I'm like well if if we could just
create value for parents enough value
that like there's something that they
want to pay for yeah that could be
interesting and if it could be like
relatively affordable and you know the
order of ten bucks let's say sure like a
month like that'll be amazing and so
that's kind of the the general direction
we've gone in we we've and that that's
been the same direction that we've
proceeded from the stop mm-hmm
so yeah another common question that
comes in over the board a lot it YC is
how is ed tech different than
traditional or whatever startups tech
startups and actually probably both of
you guys could answer this one yeah well
there's like the obvious differences I
think that we've spoken about around
like hey how distribution is different
and like those kunia things around
privacy and security you need to be
buttoned up on and how it's not quite
consumer or not quite enterprise amid
all I think but but I think the the
non-obvious one for me is is how
education isn't it's not a tech product
it's it's really like pickup like unlike
other industries I think education is
really just what happens between a
teacher and a learner
and so it's really like a very human
creation and so the role of technology
is is really like to support that not to
like replace it and
the knowledge I was use of the team is
like if you and I think this this is
very important because like the analogy
I use for the team is the difference in
a technical system and a human system
and if you're making like one perfect
technical system like Mike a MacBook
yeah or a Tesla let's say probably the
right strategy is to have like a perfect
design for it and then just like sell it
to as many people as can afford it and
hope it gets cheaper over time like it's
like design first and then give it then
sell to people but but I think if you're
working with a human system like a team
or a classroom you mean like it's
actually a really bad strategy to like
design something and then just like
impose it on people I think you actually
follow the opposite order where you get
to people and you help them design the
changes they want to make in their sin
they're like they leave their human
systems and I think that's like a
non-obvious but really important mental
model difference hmm would you agree I
haven't thought about it in those terms
but like you said this is human system
in you you need to be worried about not
worried about but conscious of the fact
that it's going to have it's not going
to be consistent across every
implementation because you have humans
evolved I would also say EdTech is a you
know has a very compelling double bottom
line you know companies can get into
this because they can they can build
interesting businesses but they can also
have a big impact on this equity problem
that's that's very interesting and and
compelling to work on it's also it's
also right before lots of solutions come
in and make things more efficient I
think if we look at kind of the
administrative level in education
systems in k-12 especially in districts
they haven't been well served by
enterprise products that are you know
they try to adapt into the education
system or by a lot of the legacy
education products so we see a lot of
great companies being built around not
being so focused on the classroom but in
this back office how do we do these
things efficiently that we've figured
out how to do well in and
price settings but but something needs
to be a little bit different in a school
setting and so there's just a lot of
room to build interesting companies in
this space still so it's an exciting
place to be working in yeah that's great
yeah all right well thanks for coming in
Sam Cheers thank you good to see ya
take care
you